we're here in front of the I-15 and as
you can see cars are moving along quite
swiftly as tonight begins another phase
of the valley-wide traffic event Nevada
Department of Transportation will be
closing Tropicana over I-15 this
happening for eight days lasting through
January 30th the second phase of
closures begin tonight after the Golden
Knights game that's a T-Mobile Arena now
for those leading the game they might
have difficulty getting out and getting
through if they don't plan accordingly
Justin Hopkins with ndot explains
immediately following the Golden Knights
game we're going to start shutting down
Tropicana Avenue and it's both
directions from Dean Martin to New York
New York during that time anybody who
would normally drive on Tropicana Avenue
over I-15 is going to have to find a new
way East-West so Russell Hacienda Harman
Spring Mountain Flamingo one of those
other East West Roads the project once
complete come 2025 will also widen
sidewalks for pedestrians going to the
T-Mobile Arena or Allegiant stadium with
the entire goal of this project to
improve our roadways as Las Vegas
continues to be a booming City with
additional Lanes added along with the
Tropicana overpass lifted tonight's
construction will begin at 11 PM
reporting near Dean Martin and Tropicana
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now